positions- werben akkusativ und da tief
jetzt verstehe ich das
mit online übungen link in der
beschreibung akkusativ legen stellen
hängen legen stellen hängen
da tief liegen stehen hängen liegen
stehen hängen
ich lege die tasche auf den tisch ich
lege die tasche auf den tisch die tasche
liegt auf dem tisch
die tasche liegt auf dem tisch
ich lege den teddybären auf das sofa ich
lege den teddybär auf das sofa der
teddybär liegt auf dem sofa der teddybär
liegt auf dem sofa ich lege das kissen
auf den sessel
ich lege das kissen auf den sessel das
kissen liegt auf dem sessel das kissen
liegt auf dem sessel
ich hänge ein foto an die wand ich hänge
ein foto an die wand
ein foto hängt an der wand ein foto
hängt an der wand
ich hänge die jacke an den stuhl ich
hänge die jacke an den stuhl
die jacke hängt am stuhl die jacke hängt
am stuhl
ich stelle das fahrrad an die wand ich
stelle das fahrrad an die wand das
fahrrad steht an der wand das fahrrad
steht an der wand
ich stelle das auto in die garage ich
stelle das auto in die garage
das auto steht in der garage
ich hänge
die lampe an die decke
die lampe hängt an der decke die lampe
hängt an der decke
ich setze mich auf den stuhl ich setze
mich auf den stuhl
ich sitze auf dem stuhl
red
ich lege mich ins bett
wird
ich
im bett
ich setze mich ins auto
ich sitze im auto ich sitze im auto
ich lege mich auf den liegestuhl ich
lege mich auf den liegestuhl
ich liege auf dem liegestuhl
ich liege auf dem liegestuhl setz dich
doch neben mich setzt dich doch neben
mich
sie sitzt neben mehr sie sitzt neben mir
die wohnung eingerichtet
da
meine neue wohnung
das ist meine neue wohnung
sie ist noch leer deshalb richte ich sie
jetzt ein
sie ist noch leer deshalb richte ich es
die lampe stelle ich in die linke ecke
das bild hänge ich an die wand
das sofa stelle ich unter das bild das
sofa stelle ich unter das bild
die pflanze stelle ich neben das sofa
das bücherregal stelle ich in die rechte
ecke das bücherregal stelle ich in die
rechte ecke
denn teppich lege ich zwischen die
pflanze und das bücherregal den teppich
lege ich zwischen die pflanze und das
bücherregal
den tisch
stelle ich vor dass sofa den tisch
stelle ich vor das sofa
und fertig ist mein wohnzimmer und
fertig ist mein wohnzimmer
der linken ecke die lampe steht in der
linken ecke
das bild hängt an der wand
das bild hängt an der wand das sofort
steht unter dem bild der sofa steht
unter dem bild der kleine tisch steht
vor dem sofa der kleine tisch steht vor
dem sofa die pflanze steht neben dem
sofa die pflanze steht neben dem sofa
der teppich liegt zwischen der pflanze
und dem bücherregal der teppich liegt
zwischen der pflanze und dem bücherregal
das bücherregal steht in der rechten
ecke
jetzt muss sich noch das schlafzimmer
einrichten
einrichten das bett stelle ich an die
wand das bett stelle ich an die wand den
kleiderschrank stelle ich neben das bett
den kleiderschrank stelle ich neben das
bett den sessel stelle ich vor den
kleiderschrank den sessel stelle ich vor
den kleiderschrank
das foto hänge ich über das bett das
foto hänge ich über das bett
die lampe hänge ich an die decke die
lampe hänge ich an die decke
denn teppich wege ich vor das bett denn
teppich lege ich vor das bett jetzt ist
auch mein schlafzimmer eingerichtet
jetzt ist auch mein schlafzimmer
eingerichtet
das bett steht an der wand das bett
steht an der wand
der kleiderschrank steht neben dem bett
der sessel steht vor dem kleiderschrank
die lampe hängt an der decke die lampe
hängt an der decke
das bild hängt an der wand
das bild hängt an der wand mit online
übungen link in der beschreibung folgt
uns halo deutsch schule
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal